[Music]
in summoning Satan news what I try he
didn't come ooh submitted by
representing the six to six the whole
San Gabriel Valley TV that's where the
Fung brothers were born the SUV you know
they're born in the six to six
whenever I get 66 on my phone it says
Pasadena so they might actually be from
New York a Christian a Christian blogger
has proclaimed that yoga was designed to
cause a demonic France verse so dumb
that's awesome
I love how Christians have the answer to
average I know thank goodness they're
alive now I know we blame your pokémon's
[ __ ] too when you're a part of I mean
there's millions of millions of billions
of Christians or whatever but it only
takes one [ __ ] group to ruin it for
the rest of them I know like the
Westboro Baptists you should watch the
video of the pastor talking about how
pokemons the devil and even his
congregation was like the other so if
your congregations not with it then you
kind of just missed the ballpark on that
when that Pokemon goal came out there
was this video that that was basically
saying that Japan is base is keeping
tabs on all Americans and all that stuff
it was like the number one ally to
America why the [ __ ] would they do it
this guy's name is Matt Walsh he wrote
an entire blog post on how he thinks
that yoga is meant to like conjure up
Satan and so he tweeted why when you
open up your chakras that means Satan
comes into your body lose what is that
in his tweet as all it does is help me
for what's Lululemon then Satan March
you know it kind of does look demonic I
love Satan worship yeah because if you
turn the their logo upside down their
horns you didn't think about that but
what a lady wears Lululemon it does
bring the devil out of me oh yeah
amen yeah so mat wash tweeted it's kind
of amazing to see all the Christians who
think nothing of going to a yoga class
there are many excellent ways to get in
shape that do not involve practicing and
him about getting a shape the best
comparison for yoga would be the Ouija
board but that is such a stretch you can
play it just for fun without any ill
intent but still you are participating
in something that was designed to
conjure spirits better to just play
Monopoly or something why mess around
you think capitalism is the devil that's
crazy man he says I've noticed that many
Christians really do not believe that
evil spirits are at work in the world at
all they laugh at the idea right along
with the antithesis that do they seem to
think the devil is a myth yet they
pretend still to believe in God they're
making a dangerous mistake
hey I mean it's kind of Oreo that
because like when I do the downward dog
I feel like that the devil's about to
enter my butthole or why can't it be God
entering your butthole do you know what
I'm saying
okay so like you the warrior 3 I think
that like certain like meditations where
like you try to leave your body I can't
understand like that being like a thing
where demons are trying to get in your
body too like the Ouija board is like a
channel for that like I couldn't follow
that train of thinking but Yoga is not
meant to get you out of your body if
anything that's meant to bring you into
your body grow and like present and like
you're focusing on the stretches so much
that you can only pay attention to this
moment it gets you completely inside
your body where demons can't enter if
you're if you're gonna go on that train
of thought that demons can take over
your body now you know what you guys
should try yoga on a surf on a little
board [ __ ] I can't even do it homeland
to do that first you know what hurts a
lot when you fall face-first in the salt
water
shit-shit it literally feels like a
large man just went to your face and
went like you're doing yoga on a
surfboard can even touch your toes like
one of those standing board things I
like to challenge myself on a daily
basis uh-huh any of your dreams do and
in my dreams but that [ __ ] [ __ ] her I
didn't because you know it's all course
[ __ ] and so you could tell who has the
weakest Court which was me I was
creating waves because that seems like
oh if you hold your core tight the boy
are you on a paddleboard a paddleboard
that's what it is
oh and so everybody else is doing it and
there's a girl clearly she's been in
this class multiple times she's all like
you can do it already shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] just so focus on your [ __ ] hole
where was this Hawaii isn't why okay
cause like the water is much more
buoyant there than here if you try doing
that here everybody would be sinking oh
yeah it was I was floating as a
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] hurt why is there
mo salt yeah have you guys seen the big
sick the main actor come on
not none Jimmy he tweeted out responding
to Matt Walsh he said I know a Christian
family that once did yoga they all
spontaneously combusted in the relatives
got chart got charred letters that said
we are in Hell now don't yoga that's
attire and then even the Church of
states him responded they said they're
like we don't like yoga they said the
Ouija board was designed as a fun party
game and only later had spooky
connotations added calling Yoga Hindu
worship is completely ignorant Matt Matt
Walsh is a superstitious buffoon who
apparently can't do a Google search
because the Google is a devil everything
is the devil yeah I grew up in a super
conservative Church too and everything
was the devil like dancing was the devil
like the guitar was the devil
it's so ridiculous man my grandma had
had no idea about rap so she was like
you can't I'm not gonna buy you any rock
music and I was like alright then just
get me some hip-hop and I was like and
she was like yeah as long as it's not
rock
Oh because of Black Sabbath you could
play a backward supposedly in a second
yeah rock music was a devil yeah you
know have a friend oh sorry I just
noticed these Hong Kong go ahead yeah I
have a friend that she she got like very
very very very Christian and whenever I
would be driving in the car I'm turn the
radio on she'd be like can you please
turn that off it's the devil's music
every music is Adele this is where a
girlfriend date ends yeah I think it is
is like he tried a yoga pose once he
couldn't do it he's like this is the
devil rap is the devil had they not
heard the song thugs mansion that's
about heaven or gangsters in Paris jesus
walks God show me the way you're doing a
new do we are oi this lock because the
Devils tried to break me down
yeah they see says you know what the
head west is young and restless yeah so
there was more going keep going I can't
remember the road while the rest is not
the good ones good yes I'm in another
response here is someone said what what
is it like to be this carrot of
everything dude right bro he's living in
have [ __ ] like you for breakfast that's
what it is I don't know the rest yeah
but those mansion was one of my favorite
songs of all totally stick one right
yeah when they did that remix with
[ __ ] NAS on that [ __ ] oh my god dude
I [ __ ] love that dude you know what's
so tight about Tupac that [ __ ]
makes me feel like a grew up in Compton
without any parents to my parents and he
makes me feel like there's hope for you
even if you need help he made me feel
like a single black mother yeah let me
feel like I was Brenda and I got a baby
you know that [ __ ] was tight
I know Oh a tree dude I wish I was a
blackberry oh yes sweeter the juice yeah
iconic we do this in a lot of Tupac I
feel like you listen to either mariachi
or a lot of white people rock music
actually listen to all of em alright
that's a rat like Bone Thugs Obama
tell me what are they when there ain't
no place to run I think is tell me what
you're gonna do what you gonna do I
[ __ ] love that [ __ ] sound just like
them yeah exactly fun things in
disharmony pop-top revenge is like
revenge is like the sweetest joy next to
getting [ __ ] yeah and I agree until I
grew up and I realized that to be a
bigger man and you don't need to have
revenge in your life wasn't he supposed
to rise from the dead in 2003 I know he
didn't he went to the Bahamas cuz he was
like ah he's like I'm over this me what
happened a hip hop we're talking want
this guy think oh yeah tell us more
about mr. crazy guy crazy to puck you
did it again it was the devil that made
us not talk about Christianity you see
that walks all possessed us yeah well I
just have more responses here like
Twitter responses someone said my
neighbors started doing yoga and then
mysteriously my dog died three years
later [ __ ] they tie those two together I
think they're just trolling yeah chuckle
my friend needs and I said gesundheit
and now we're both German I should have
been more careful
should have bless them for sure yeah and
then this other one so I'm gonna have to
assume your celebration of Christmas
doesn't include decorating a tree how
could they say yoga is a pagan ritual I
can't picture a bunch of witches doing
yoga
not me kind of like the Halloween kind
yeah don't be taking Christmas away I
don't like you most of my senses can you
say happy holidays and not Merry
Christmas
no [ __ ] you what's the difference I say
both that's right I mean I'm what's the
difference though like between might be
all days a minute your ones more
inclusive to like it's more
all-encompassing that could be
everything oh I thought happy holidays
was the lazy way to say it because it
also adds new years oh because it's the
holidays the whole week I'm gonna say
whatever the [ __ ] I want you take it or
leave it Merry Christmas
I don't want to hear it well that's your
choice done [ __ ] deal with it
[Music]